All sessions have a file system backing them that can
be accessed. If you go to the URL that is
here's a previous run, for example, that we generated a
comic book from. If we open in a new tab
that same URL but we remove the web page part
so that we just access the root directory of that
session. We can access the file system itself for that
session. Now this comes with a number of interesting features
First of all, we can download the entire directory as
a zip file. We can look at any markdown
files, we can look at any HTML files and directly
view them, of course, and we can also view markdown
files. As either markdown, which this
will cause download, or you can view the markdown files
as HTML files that does a dynamic rendering. You can
also view them as text files. If you, this is
handy if you want to view the markdown source, um
in a way that won't trigger a download for your
browser. And you can also view markdown files as PDFs
and that also does a dynamic rendering of the markdown
file into PDF format. Additionally, the
file system has built-in Git support, so you can view
the current status, you can commit the directory. If
you're not aware, uh, Git is a version control system
for file systems so that it's basically like a time
machine so that you can track all of the file
changes and if needed rollback. Um, accessing
the root file system for any given session via this
interface gives you a powerful, um, backdoor
into the system functionality. Um, and provides
a good level of hackability and transparency for any, Cognotic
applications. Finally, I'd like to point out that the physical
location of the file system is shown here. Uh, so
if you want, you can mount this with a development
environment or you can open it in the file system
explorer or whatever you want to do. I hope that
functionality is useful to you.